kalou hola
hola a todos buenos días
bienvenidos a esta capacitación hola
cristina buenos días
hola hola espero todos se encuentren muy
bien esta mañana vamos a comenzar hoy
bienvenidos todos gracias por
acompañarnos y vamos a comenzar con esta
capacitación que tenemos muchas noticias
para ustedes muchas cosas que están
sucediendo en en kant academy y que
realmente como docentes nos van a
aportar muchísimo en nuestro salón de
clases entonces voy a compartir con
ustedes la presentación de esta
capacitación
ok
tener momentos para compartir
[Música]
ok
la pueden ver
perfecto ok bueno nuevamente bienvenidos
a este módulo 2 de esta capacitación de
khan academy
estamos aquí obviamente con el objetivo
de apoyarlos a maximizar todos los
resultados académicos en este regreso a
clases y sobre todo ahorita que estamos
comenzando con todas las ganas y toda la
energía entonces queremos nosotros
apoyarlos y acompañarlos en este proceso
para que ustedes puedan ser testigos de
una mejora en los resultados académicos
de todos sus alumnos el enlace para esta
presentación es este que ven aquí en la
pantalla si tienen su dispositivo a la
mano pueden entrar es jeje punto jeje
diagonal b deje 5 h si no tienen un
dispositivo electrónico a la mano
entonces lo que pueden hacer es tomarle
una foto a la pantalla y más adelante
pueden bajarla ya sea en su celular o en
o en su computador
les voy a dar unos minutos para que
entren aquellos que tienen su
dispositivo o que tomen la foto
saludos miguel de torreón alejandra
flores guzmán salvador guillén alejandro
lópez gonzalo cauich muchas gracias por
estar todos aquí de verdad agradecemos
su esfuerzo su interés su energía mi
nombre es patricia garcía yo trabajo
para el textil y trabajo en conjunto con
a christina en khan academy para
capacitar a los docentes
yo fui maestro maestra de matemáticas y
de ciencias durante 10 años de mi vida
en mi colegio americano de la ciudad de
mexico
entonces al ser docente también entiendo
no cuáles son nuestras necesidades
cuáles son nuestras frustraciones a
veces no y estoy consciente de que
muchas veces tenemos muy poco tiempo
y es mucho lo que tenemos que hacer
entonces por eso está khan academy aquí
para ayudarnos a hacer todavía hasta
volvernos más eficientes y más efectivos
en nuestro trabajo bueno vamos a
comenzar entonces como ya todos saben
porque yo creo que muchos de ustedes ya
han utilizado khan academy nuestra
misión es ofrecer una educación de
primer nivel para cualquier persona en
cualquier lugar en cualquier momento y
esto es muy importante porque la
plataforma de cada cadena que khan
academy además de que es gratis está
disponible en cualquier lugar donde sea
que estén nuestros estudiantes son
nosotros y en cualquier momento a
cualquier hora del día esta base la
agenda para la capacitación de hoy
primero hablaremos de campeonato esta
esta parte está muy interesante les va a
gustar mucho
vamos a explicarles que es como comenzar
de qué se trata qué es lo que hay que
hacer para participar y después vamos a
ver el la sección de cómo podemos
motivar y reconocer los logros de
nuestros alumnos durante este reto que
debemos hacer para poder ser reconocidos
nosotros como un maestro campeón y cómo
podemos entrenar a otros cómo podemos
eliminar clases viejas y crear clases
nuevas junto con esto veremos cómo
podemos inscribirnos un campeonato
asignar tareas y vamos a ver también las
nuevas características de la plataforma
hay muchas cosas nuevas en la plataforma
de khan academy que están todavía más
increíbles que lo que tenían antes
entonces queremos platicarles de qué se
tratan estos cambios qué es lo nuevo que
hay y qué ventaja vamos a sacar nosotros
como docentes
estos nuevos cambios de estas nuevas
características de la plataforma y vamos
a hablar algo de lo que le llaman
mentalidad de crecimiento que es un
concepto que tiene khan academy que que
está manejando muy fuertemente y que
realmente nos va a ayudar muchísimo a
crear mente es mucho más fuertes y más y
más
pues sí más poderosas digamos a nuestros
alumnos no son diferentes ejercicios que
ellos van a desarrollar para ir
creciendo en su manera de pensar y
seguir avanzando pues vamos a comenzar
con qué es campeonato que lo que debemos
hacer para inscribirnos y cuándo
comienza bueno no sé si ustedes han
escuchado de campeonato de caná khadem y
la verdad es una es un programa
increíble y es excelente para ahorita
para el inicio de clases para motivar a
nuestros alumnos para engancharlos a
nuestra clase no para darles a conocer
esta plataforma y como los puede ayudar
entonces el campeonato de canacar m es
un programa gratuito donde va a tener
una duración de 10 semanas y cuál es el
objetivo como les digo es impulsar el
aprendizaje motivar a nuestros alumnos
enganchar a nuestros alumnos en este
regreso a clases no que todos regresamos
no con este fue con ganas con muchas
ganas pero a la vez pues esto llegamos
de las vacaciones etcétera y nos cuesta
no volvernos a conectar con la escuela y
khan academy nos va a ayudar mucho
el proceso no va vamos a combinar en
este programa actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento y mucha práctica no a
través de los diferentes materiales que
khan academy nos ofrece como ustedes
bien saben khan academy no solamente se
trata de vídeos se trata también de
artículos de ejercicios de muchos
recursos que realmente pueden ayudar a
nuestros alumnos a ser mejores
estudiantes ya aumentar su confianza en
las matemáticas y su motivación sabemos
todos que bueno matemáticas y ciencias
son dos asignaturas que a nuestros
jóvenes les cuesta trabajo no a veces
les tienen un poco de miedo tienen esta
mentalidad de que yo no puedo y por
tanto le dan un poco a las matemáticas
entonces yo creo que es este inicio de
clases es una oportunidad excelente para
poder darles las herramientas a nuestros
alumnos y que descubran que no son malos
en matemáticas no que pueden realmente
ser buenos con las herramientas
adecuadas cuando comienza este
campeonato bueno las inscripciones se
abrieron ayer señores el 13 de agosto
pero sin embargo el reto comienza hasta
el 10 de septiembre y termina el 16 de
noviembre
entonces ya desde ahora podemos comenzar
a escribirnos ahora les vamos a decir
cómo
donde pienses cosa quién puede
participar en esto el campeonato está
abierto para todos los estudiantes de la
republica mexicana desde primaria
primaria perdón a bachillerato pueden
participar y está pensado como les decía
para motivar a los estudiantes sin
importar su nivel
el programa se adapta fácilmente a todos
los niveles no de esta todos los
horarios a todos los ambientes escolares
el principales son los principios del
campeonato como como les digo el el
objetivo del campeonato es alcanzar a
todos nuestros alumnos de primaria a
bachillerato inspirar confianza
cambiarles esa mentalidad y esa visión
que tienen tanto de las matemáticas como
de las ciencias que aprendan sin
importar su nivel algunos son más
avanzados otros están más retrasados
pero finalmente khan academy les da la
oportunidad nos da la oportunidad de
poder personalizar el aprendizaje y esos
maestros ustedes saben que en
condiciones normales nos es imposible no
porque tenemos muchos alumnos y muchas
tareas además de dar clases muchas
tareas administrativas que cumplir como
docentes entonces de esta herramienta me
da la oportunidad de poder personalizar
el aprendizaje para mis alumnos de
manera que ellos puedan ir ganando
confianza y sentirse más seguros en el
manejo de la asignatura y va promoviendo
poco a poco una mentalidad de
crecimiento por otro lado también este
programa está hecho para empoderarnos a
ustedes
de que ustedes puedan no solamente
ayudar a sus alumnos de una mejor manera
pero también ustedes no tener más tiempo
porque finalmente esta herramienta esta
plataforma nos ayuda en la obtención de
reportes y nos ayuda como les digo de
una manera mucho más fácil a diferenciar
de nuestro dentro de nuestro salón de
clases a poder realmente no trabajar con
las diferentes los diferentes niveles no
de matemáticas dentro de nuestro salón
de clases no y nos va haciendo esta
frase me encanta no todos somos héroes
la verdad es que yo considero que todos
los docentes de este país somos héroes
no y necesitamos ese reconocimiento no
hay necesitamos esas herramientas que
nos permitan demostrar lo mucho que
podemos hacerlo entonces es flexible la
herramienta y yo creo que es muy fácil
de implementar dentro de los salones de
clase también como les digo esta es una
herramienta que pretende alcanzar a
todos y darle la oportunidad a todos los
alumnos de este país para que puedan
sus habilidades matemáticas y de
ciencias y además de todo es divertido
porque nuestros alumnos en el proceso
van a van divirtiéndose y van a
encontrar los retos sí y es una
plataforma que los motivan hoy yo porque
todos los los chicos de todos los
niveles les gusta ser reconocidos y esta
plataforma reconoce el esfuerzo de los
alumnos los motiva a seguir avanzando ya
seguir buscando no esté nuevas maneras
de progresar ahora cómo podemos
participar como profesores y esta es una
parte muy muy importante lo que queremos
que les quede así muy muy claro entonces
los profesores en el momento que ustedes
agregue se inscriben digamos a
campeonato automáticamente todas las
clases que ustedes tienen creadas o que
han creado van a quedar automáticamente
inscritas en campeonato no ustedes
agregan sus clases en khan academy
ustedes primero si no tienen una cuenta
lo obviamente lo primero es crear su
cuenta en khan academy
abrir sus clases en khan academy y
empezar a asignar contenido etcétera y
escribiremos inscribirnos en campeonato
en la descripción es muy sencilla en el
momento que ustedes abren la plataforma
hoy día que ahorita la vamos a abrir
para que lo vean ahí
automáticamente dice inscribirte a
campeonato está vas a hacer clic y como
les digo automáticamente quedan
inscritas las clases que ya tienen
creadas dentro del campeonato
entonces los profesores van usando las
herramientas de khan academy para
asignar actividades y prácticas a su
clase el requisito aquí y lo vamos a ver
también más adelante el requisito aquí
es asignar mínimo tres actividades tres
recursos a cada uno de sus estudiantes
todos los durante al menos semana en una
semana nosotros los alumnos si vamos a
poner un ejemplo si tenemos 20 alumnos y
ahí le vamos a asignar tres recursos por
semana cada uno estamos hablando de 60
actividades entonces las 60 actividades
tienen que ser con test
de manera que los alumnos puedan
realmente ver su progreso y ir ganando
puntos para lograr los objetivos de
campeonato entonces esa es la única
labor del profesor asignar cada semana
tres de diferentes recursos a cada uno
de nuestros alumnos
y vamos a contar con una plataforma que
está muy divertida que nos puede ir
enseñando cuál es nuestro avance eso voy
a compartir ustedes son los vídeos de
cómo los alumnos se mas emocionan con
esto y vamos a estar recibiendo como
profesores datos e información sobre
cada uno de nuestros estudiantes y sobre
el progreso que vamos teniendo como
clase como podemos participar como
alumnos no los estudiantes lo único que
deben hacer es completar los ejercicios
que les envía su profesor a su propio
ritmo en su propio tiempo como les digo
lo mínimo es tres recursos en una semana
muchas veces asignamos hasta más no la
verdad es que vienen siendo muy pocos
dentro de una semana y entonces ellos
tienen ese tiempo para poder
y contestar estos materiales digamos que
asigna el profesor y con esto ellos van
ganando puntos y medallas y premios en
línea etcétera que van siendo de edición
limitada creados únicamente para este
programa la clase entera puede ver su
progreso a través de un tablero que
también ha sido creado específicamente
para este proyecto y entonces este
tablero al inscribirse van a tener
acceso como maestros a este tablero iba
a poder van a poder ir viendo el avance
en los momentos clave las metas
alcanzadas etcétera y la clase también
puede ir celebrando no los premios que
van ganando en línea las medallas los
premios digitales las escuelas que
alcancen más metas van a recibir un
paquete sorpresa de canacar en qué son
los premios los premios bueno están
diseñados para celebrar el esfuerzo
tanto de profesores como de los alumnos
porque también estamos conscientes en
khan academy que ustedes como docentes
están poniendo mucho esfuerzo muchas
ganas estén motivar a sus alumnos y
su compromiso no entonces nosotros
queremos también celebrar y reconocer
este compromiso por parte de ustedes con
el campeonato cuenta con medallas y
premios virtuales como les comento
hechos especialmente para este programa
y también habrá premios especiales para
los profesores participantes ahora cómo
funciona
este
el campeonato no el primero lo primero
que nosotros vamos a hacer como les
decía antes que nada inscribirnos esta
va a ser nuestro primer paso y ahora les
voy a decir como y lo sencillo que es
una vez que ya estamos inscritos y que
comienza con ese que ahorita está
abierta las inscripciones hasta el 10 de
septiembre comienza ya el campeonato
como tal y desde ese momento vamos a
empezar a asignar a nuestros alumnos
tres recursos por semana a todos los
alumnos y todos los alumnos tienen que
contestarla para contestar los dos y
enviarlos de otra manera la clase no va
a progresar porque está diseñado de esta
manera porque nosotros queremos motivar
a todos los alumnos te sabemos no que en
ocasiones en un salón de clases hay
alumnos que son muy comprometidos muy
responsables pero hay otros que no
entonces para que realmente podamos
avanzar como salón de clases como un
grupo necesitamos la participación del
100% de nuestros alumnos
vamos a ir fortaleciendo las habilidades
de los estudiantes van fortaleciendo el
conocimiento y el aprendizaje de los
los conceptos que ustedes van
enseñándoles en clase a través de
práctica
personalizada a través de vídeos a
través de artículos etcétera también con
esto vamos desarrollando sus mentes
creando estrategias de aprendizaje y
creando una mentalidad mucho más fuerte
no hay una mentalidad del logro yo creo
que eso es muy importante
lograremos alcanzar nuestros alumnos no
realmente hacerles creer que si pueden
que sí que se la crean o que si pueden
que tienen la mentalidad que tienen el
todas las características necesarias
para ser triunfadores dentro de estas
asignaturas y finalmente vamos a
celebrar el avance y los logros de los
alumnos yo creo que en cualquier
programa esta parte es vital a todos nos
gusta ser reconocidos ya nuestros
alumnos aún más entonces esta parte es
muy importante no qué plan no qué
estrategias vamos a seguir para poder
reconocer en nuestros alumnos su
esfuerzo sus logros y seguir motivando
entonces
la plata fue bueno lo que viene siendo
el campeonato vamos a tener como les
digo este tablero en donde podremos ir
midiendo el progreso dentro de nuestro
salón de clase hasta que lleguen al cien
por ciento es realmente un tablero que
motiva mucho a los alumnos los emociona
muchos va iniciando o no el tablero de
progreso indicándonos el nivel que los
alumnos van logrando a través del
programa y van recibiendo a través de
este tablero también los premios
digitales que como les decía fueron
creados especialmente para este programa
quiero compartir con ustedes dos vídeos
que uno es de brasil y otros en eeuu de
como como éste no este programa los ha
motivado y los han entusiasmado vamos a
ver primero este
esto es en eeuu
[Música]
y
entonces bueno a mí me emociona mucho
esto no porque finalmente podemos ver
cómo los alumnos hacen propio hacen suyo
este sus logros no y pueden realmente
ser parte de un grupo parte de algo y yo
creo que el sentido de pertenecer y de
ser parte de un logro en común es muy
importante en hoy y que mejor que
comenzar nuestro año escolar con algo
así no con algo que los enganche que los
motive y sobre todo también fomentar ese
trabajo en equipo no ese trabajo en
grupo es por eso que requerimos el 100
por ciento la participación perdón del
100 por ciento de nuestros alumnos
ahora tenemos estas actividades para
promocionar promover una mentalidad de
crecimiento no entonces aquí estás son
diferentes actividades y diferentes
pues sí ejercicios digamos que los
alumnos van realizando que no
necesariamente están conectados a lo que
es matemáticas o lo que ciencias
simplemente son actividades que los
chicos van desarrollando con el objetivo
de hacer crecer su mente no de ir
desarrollando habilidades estratégicas
para el aprendizaje no para el
entendimiento etcétera no entonces como
puede no ser hasta la resiliencia no
como puedo yo lograr el éxito no a pesar
de ciertos fracasos no cual vos voy a
escucharla de no puedo la de si puedo
cómo puedo convertir mis errores en
éxitos entonces todo esto eso lo que
tenemos que trabajar con nuestros
alumnos no y qué mejor que a principio
de año para que ellos puedan cambiar ese
switch que tienen en su mente a veces de
no puedo no entonces esta parte es creo
fundamental para poder realmente motivar
a nuestros alumnos a que siempre
persigan el éxito
este es me encanta me este testimonio de
maribel una maestra de matemáticas del
conalep dice el logro más significativo
es que los estudiantes tienen ahora más
interés por aprender matemáticas lo
hacen ahora de una manera significativa
orientada a su vida real y me encanta
porque yo como maestra de matemáticas
que ha utilizado por muchos años la
plataforma de khan academy realmente
también ha sido testigo de esto no ha
tenido alumnos digo como todos ustedes
también que llegan frustrados a la clase
de matemáticas que no les gusta llegan
enojados no están desmotivados porque
simplemente el nivel de frustración es
alto no y cuando van y vamos dándole
esta oportunidad de trabajar a su propio
ritmo de trabajar en aquellas
habilidades que ellos en las que están
ellos débiles en que no entienden
etcétera poco a poco van ganando esa
confianza van generando ese crecimiento
y van cambiando la visión lo que tienen
sobre la materia entonces es muy cierto
esto qué
que nos comparte la maestra del conalep
entonces recuerden el campeonato empieza
el 10 de septiembre las inscripciones
están abiertas desde ayer si ustedes
entran ya a la plataforma vamos a entrar
en unos minutos podrán ver que ya está
el botón para inscribirnos no entonces
sin embargo comienza como tal el 10 de
septiembre
vamos a ver ahora cómo motivar y
reconocer los logros de tus alumnos
durante este reto yo creo que es muy
importante digo primero conocer a
nuestros alumnos porque la medida en que
los conocemos podemos realmente
saber no es que les motiva como nos
enganchamos que les gusta etcétera no y
como es principio de año pues muchas
veces no los conocemos sin embargo con
los docentes yo creo que siempre y no
solamente para campeonato no solamente
en khan academy siempre debemos tener un
plan para motivar a nuestros alumnos y
para reconocer sus esfuerzos y sus
logros no entonces yo creo que es
importante desarrollar un plan de qué
voy a hacer para motivarlos lo que voy a
hacer para reconocer sus logros yo creo
que para esto muy importante lo primero
que hay que hacer es tener objetivos
bien claros que los alumnos conozcan
cuáles son los objetivos dentro del
campeonato llegar al 100% de los puntos
para que podamos recibir los premios
digitales no entonces plantearles
objetivos claros de manera que entonces
ya podamos nosotros como docentes
reconocer sus logros yo cuando tenía mis
alumnos que yo tenía alumnos de
secundaria no pero digamos entre primero
de secundaria más o menos segundo de
secundaria
y yo lo que hacía no se desea ok para
tal fecha tenemos que tener cubierto tal
porcentaje de la de la unidad de la
misión etcétera en khan academy o tener
tanto tiempo de práctica dentro de la
plataforma etcétera de puedes poner
diferentes objetivos y si lo aquellos
que lo lograban pues llegaba yo ya sea
con con monfils o llegaban hacia una
compraba una pizza y los invita durante
la hora de recreo
o simplemente un reconocimiento no un
diploma un aplauso un poster está fuera
del salón dentro del salón pero ya cada
quien lo puede hacer a su manera y bien
en sus posibilidades pero siempre tener
un plan para reconocer aquellos alumnos
que están realmente dando todo su
esfuerzo y motivar a aquellos que no lo
están haciendo no entonces contó
pensamos también motivar no la
perseverancia y excelencia en los
alumnos hay que siempre decirles bueno
te sacaste en la plataforma en tu
ejercicio 70 ve por el 86 siempre hay
posibilidad
y practicando y sigue aumentando hasta
que realmente llegues a dominar el
concepto no entonces no no hace los
conformistas no entonces siempre motivar
la excelencia en ellos no y finalmente
cómo vamos a evaluar el desempeño y el
esfuerzo de nuestros alumnos en khan acá
en allá hay maestros que dicen bueno yo
voy a considerar este las calificaciones
digamos que me da cada académico les voy
a dar un tanto porcentaje dentro de la
calificación total
eso ya depende pues de cada plantel de
cada docente etcétera pero yo creo que
sí es importante que le demos cierto
valor a las actividades que los alumnos
no realizan dentro de la plataforma
qué debo hacer reconocido que debo hacer
yo docente para ser reconocido como un
maestro campeón entonces primero bueno
vamos a hablar de este programa de
capacitación
este es el módulo 2 del programa de
capacitación de khan academy que tiene
por objetivo reconocer el esfuerzo que
ustedes están haciendo por conocer la
plataforma por manejar la plataforma no
por realmente volverse campeones dentro
de esta plataforma
entonces el módulo 1 tuvo lugar el
primero de agosto les voy a compartir
más adelante el enlace para este vídeo
que se realizó el primero de agosto en
este módulo 1 hablamos de los primeros
pasos en khan academy cuál es el plan de
acción para el año escolar 2018 2019 en
la implementación de mejores prácticas
cuáles fueron los son los lineamientos y
también hablamos un poco de cómo conocer
la plataforma a fondo y las nuevas
características de la plataforma en esta
estamos como lo mencioné en la agenda
hablando de campeonato vamos a hablar de
como maneras de reconocer y de motivar a
nuestros alumnos vamos también a hablar
de cómo puedo crear clases cómo puedo
borrar mis clases como puedo asignar
estas tareas que debo asignar durante
campeonato y también vamos a ver las
nuevas características de la plataforma
que como les comenté hay cambios
increíbles o sacan a academia acaba de
tener como un nuevo look por decirlo así
acaban de hacer muchos cambios para
final su objetivo es siempre darnos el
mejor servicio como docentes entonces
eso se los quiero compartir porque la
verdad está muy padre para todos
nosotros y en el módulo 3 que va a ser
más adelante les daremos información
octubre-noviembre-diciembre el objetivo
será motivar a los alumnos durante el
campeonato no como podemos realizar
ceremonias no para reconocer los logros
los esfuerzos de los chicos la
preparación para lo para este exámenes
etcétera y finalmente el reconocimiento
para ustedes
entonces no duden no duden de verdad
participar en campeonato para motivar a
sus alumnos no compra y también lo que
nosotros queremos que ustedes hagan es
que compartan sus experiencias con
nosotros nos encanta de verdad en khan
academy escuchar de ustedes escuchar sus
preocupaciones sus logros sus objetivos
entonces esa parte es increíble para
nosotros entonces yo quiero de verdad a
través de este webinar motivarlos a que
participen en canal en campeonato es una
experiencia maravillosa ustedes se van a
dar cuenta que vas a una herramienta que
va a cambiar el tono del inicio de
clases en sus alumnos es gratis no hay
nada que pagarlo en nada que hacer y es
simplemente disfrutar de estas 10
semanas y aprender con nuestros alumnos
y disfrutar el proceso junto con
nuestros alumnos y les pedimos también
que compartan con nosotros esas
experiencias no del logro que tomen
vídeos dentro de su salón de clases
durante mientras están hasta con su
celular mientras los chicos están viendo
el tablero del
no ver sus reacciones conocerlos nada
más a fondo y lo compartan con nosotros
porque yo creo que para todos esto es
muy significativo y es el pre
emocionante ver cómo podemos cambiar la
mentalidad de nuestros jóvenes
no sé si tengamos preguntas hasta acá
christina
aquí les dice josé luís igualito vázquez
un incentivo de motivación para el
trabajo en la plataforma sería un evento
en el plantel con el reconocimiento por
parte de las autoridades
eso me parece una muy buena idea vaya y
creo que algo se tiene contemplado ya
khan academy más adelante les les irá
diciendo pero y les vamos a dar también
ideas nosotros de que pueden hacerlo qué
tipo de ceremonias pueden hacer etcétera
no a medida que se vaya acercando el
final de campeonato
y ahorita les voy a decir cómo pueden
inscribirse me preguntan y niza van y
cómo se pueden inscribir yo les voy a
decir ahorita lo sencillo que es
ok entonces vamos
vamos entonces a continuar con la
presentación y bueno vamos a hablar de
cómo puedo eliminar clases viejas y
crear clases nuevas entonces antes que
nada bueno les voy a pedir a todos que
aquellos que tienen su dispositivo a la
mano vamos a entrar a ese punto khan
academy punto org les pido que entren a
este enlace abren una ventana / pongan
este enlace y vamos a entrar de lleno a
la plataforma
la maravilla de no de khan academy en
español
es que nosotros ya estamos alineados a
la sep entonces todos pueden tener la
tranquilidad de que cuando están
asignando recursos realmente estamos
siguiendo los lineamientos de la zeta no
entonces esto es algo enorme para méxico
nosotros podemos confiar totalmente en
que la plataforma va a cumplir nuestras
necesidades y va a ir alineada a
nuestras necesidades
entonces una vez que yo entro y voy a
cambiar aquí me voy a salir por un
momento de la de la plataforma
bueno antes que antes de salirme del
perdón de la presentación que lo que yo
si ustedes no tienen una cuenta no han
creado una cuenta que yo creo que la
mayoría de los que están en este webinar
ya han utilizado khan academy pero si no
lo han utilizado es muy sencillo crear
su cuenta y no quiero ir sobre esto
porque como les digo pienso que la
mayoría ya lo tiene pero ustedes tienen
que ir únicamente al enlace a ese punto
khan academy punto org hacer clic en
maestros empiecen aquí y una vez que
hace un clic les dicen les dan tres
diferentes opciones de como como
registrarse ya sea con su jeep los ya
sea con su cuenta de facebook o ya sea
con su correo electrónico yo siempre les
recomiendo que lo hagan con su correo
electrónico porque porque si después
cierran su facebook etcétera ya
perdieron toda su información
entonces háganlo a través de su correo
electrónico una vez que hagan clic en
registrarte con tu correo electrónico se
les va a abrir una tercera ventana en
donde lo único que tienen que hacer es
poner su correo electrónico
hombre su apellido y crear una
contraseña por favor apunten la
contraseña en un lugar donde recuerden
que está donde la tengan segura para que
no pierdan su información sus clases
etcétera si es que la olvidan así de
fácil es abrir una cuenta en khan
academy en caso de que no la tengan
ahora en caso de que ya tengan su cuenta
crear una clase es muy sencillo para
esto me voy a salir de la presentación
voy a entrar de lleno a la plataforma
ok déjeme aquí me cambió ok
cuando una vez que yo creo mi plataforma
en cuenta automáticamente me va a llevar
deme permiso porque aquí hay no es que
me estoy llevando haciendo clic
incorrecto ok entonces una vez que yo
creo a mi cuenta automáticamente me va a
llevar a esta página ustedes si su
cuenta es nueva no van a tener nada aquí
estas son clases que yo he creado ok
entonces aquí ustedes no tendrían nada
esto tendría vacío y fíjense aquí como
ya aparece el botón para inscribirte al
campeonato si ustedes ya tienen creadas
clases dentro de khan academy al hacer
clic en inscríbete al campeonato
automáticamente sus clases que ya tienen
creadas van a quedar inscritas en
campeonato un requisito importante que
quiero que sepan y que entendamos todos
muy bien es que las clases deben tener
un mínimo de 10 alumnos si yo tuve una
clase de dos alumnos
participar no no va a participar las
clases deben tener un mínimo de 10
alumnos ahora qué pasa si yo me escribo
después de que ya empezó no hay problema
podemos inscribirnos si el campeonato
empieza el septiembre 10 y yo a finales
de septiembre quiero crear una clase
inscribir la la creo y automáticamente
queda inscrita no pasa nada podemos
inscribirnos en cualquier momento eso
que nos quede también muy claro siempre
va a estar abierta la posibilidad para
inscribirnos aunque ya haya comenzado el
campeonato entonces es muy fácil con que
yo haga inscribir al campeonato todas
mis clases ya creadas van a quedar
automáticamente inscritas nuevamente
repito siempre y cuando tengan diez o
más alumnos ahora con lo puedo agregar
una nueva clase entonces yo aquí siempre
tengo un botón que dice agregar una
clase voy a hacer clic en agregar una
clase se abre esta ventana voy a poner
el nombre de la clase vamos a poner
ejemplo hoy
módulo
2 de esta capacitación le voy a dar
siguiente y en este voy a seleccionar
qué curso es el que voy a dar en esta
clase no hay aquí van todas las
diferentes opciones que tengo primero de
primaria recuerden que tanto primaria
como hasta bachillerato podemos
participar en campeonato entonces voy a
poner primero de secundaria ok o puede
ser biología química física ingeniería
eléctrica etcétera y le doy siguiente y
ya aquí el tercer paso es invitar a mis
alumnos y puedo invitarlos a través de
diferentes opciones recuerden que si
estoy trabajando con google claro puedo
invitarlos a través de google classroom
importar a todos mis alumnos de google
classroom o bien puedo enviar una
invitación por correo electrónico obvio
para esto necesito tener a la mano los
correos electrónicos de mis alumnos no
entonces muchas veces de basta que no
entremos a clases no los tenemos no
entonces voy a invitar aquí me voy a
invitar a mí misma para que vean
no voy a invitar
ahora otra opción que podemos invitar
también a nuestros alumnos es a través
de un código no entonces aquí en el
momento en que yo invito a alumnos
automáticamente la clase queda creada
pues aquí ya me hable me dice tu clase
ya está creada qué quieres hacer a
continuación quieres empezar a explorar
el contenido de primero de secundaria
qué quieres hacer entonces yo hago clic
y ahí ya se está cargando mi clase ya
que tengo aquí el contenido de todos los
conceptos que un estudiante de primero
de secundaria debe aprender así de
sencillo debo regresar aquí en lista
están todos mis alumnos que yo invitados
y yo quiero agregar nuevos alumnos
siempre le voy a hacer clic en agregar
nuevos estudiantes y aquí nuevamente me
aparecen las diferentes opciones
recuerden que siempre que yo genero una
clase en khan academy automáticamente se
crea un código para esa clase que es en
este caso es este que está aquí arriba
se receta y v9
para mí y esto yo le sugiero que para mí
está en la medida la forma más efectiva
y eficiente de invitar a mis alumnos
porque aprovechó que están todos juntos
todos reunidos al mismo tiempo en mi
salón de clases cuando los tengo a todos
juntitos el primer día de clases el
segundo etcétera y les pido que vayan a
khan academy punto por diagonal join
ellos al entrar aquí vamos a hacer clic
ahí entran a esta a este enlace y aquí
en únete a la clase ponen el código que
yo puedo apuntar el pizarrón en grande
etcétera o puedo imprimirlo y dárselos a
ellos y aquí en esta sección que dice
código ellos ponen el código y ponen
únete a la clase así de sencillo
entonces es una forma muy fácil de poder
tener a todos nuestros alumnos dentro de
la clase no porque luego si pasa que
pasa un mes después si los alumnos
siguen sin inscribirse porque perdieron
el correo etcétera entonces en la manera
más sencilla y más rápida de hacerlo
ahora a veces nos surge la duda de cómo
elimino clases no entonces hay veces que
tenemos clases que ya no estamos dando
las clases del año pasado etcétera como
la eliminó y para esto es muy sencillo
les voy a enseñar vamos a eliminar esta
misma no que que acabamos de crear
entonces para yo eliminar clases viejas
clases antiguas lo dice lo fácil que es
voy a seleccionar la clase que yo quiero
eliminar si la abro y aquí en
configuración le voy a ir a
configuración
me voy a hago clic en configuración y
automáticamente aquí me sale la
posibilidad de eliminar esta clase me
sale el botón de eliminar esta clase
hago clic en eliminar me dice seguro
quieres eliminarla si quiero eliminarla
y automáticamente la clase se borra de
mí
de mi cuenta de khan academy ojo aquí yo
estoy eliminando una clase no estoy
eliminando mi cuenta me cuentas y
abierta
yo puedo seguir creando nuevas clases
con este procedimiento lo único que hice
fue eliminar una clase que ya no utilizó
que ya no me sirve case sin embargo mi
cuenta sigue intacta y puedo seguir
agregando nuevas clases entonces eso es
importante que lo entendamos preguntas
hasta aquí
pedro dice tengo las clases creadas
desde hace unos días
tiene que ser él
con eso ya estoy inscrito acuérdense que
tienen que inscribirse cuando entran
aquí a khan academy tienen que hacer
click en inscribirse al campeonato es
importante si no hacen eso no se hace
solito o sea no cada camino va a saber
que ustedes quieren participar en
campeonato si no hacen clic en
inscribirse ok entonces esa parte es muy
importante que lo hagan y si
automáticamente sus clases ya creadas
quedan inscritas en campeonato
preguntas hasta aquí christine
comentarios
algunas personas están preguntando el
registro y los correos que deben usar
para crear clases
ok pues yo generalmente lo que
recomiendo es que utilicen su correo del
plantel si tienen un correo profesional
es el que ustedes van a utilizar pero él
y el que ustedes utilicen para abrir su
cuenta de khan academy es el mismo que
van a utilizar para registrarse o sea
siempre utilicen el mismo correo de
manera que realmente los puedan
localizar entonces el mismo correo que
yo utilizo para abrir mi cuenta en khan
academy es el mismo correo que voy a
utilizar para registrarme para poder
recibir información por parte de canadá
de mí sobre los logros sobre el avance
sobre información nueva etcétera
entonces siempre hágalo con el mismo
correo
ok vamos a ver cómo vamos a asignar
tareas y aquí en esta parte me voy a
volver a pasar a la plataforma y esta
parte está increíble porque es nueva
esto ya lo cambiaron en khan academy
entonces ustedes ya han tenido esta esta
capacitación antes o ya han visto un
vídeo de cómo usar la plataforma esto va
a ser nuevo para ustedes entonces voy a
entrar otra vez de nuevo a la plataforma
pues ahora la cama
ok recuerden para aquellos que ya
conocen un poco la plataforma que
siempre que hago clic en khan academy
siempre me va a llevar a mi página de
inicio digamos no y que yo la tengo
seleccionada como página como mi página
de tutor recuerden que en cada cambio
puedo cambiar mi rol de profesor a
maestro no en este caso yo entro a mi
rol como maestro entonces tengo aquí
todas las clases que yo tengo creadas no
entonces voy a entrar en esta vamos a
poner este
vamos a ver qué clase voy a entrar para
aceptarles para demostrarles algunas
vamos a ver está ok entonces cómo puedo
asignar recursos dentro de una clase no
entonces yo en esta clase en este caso
digo tengo
no seleccione aquí
primero de secundaria entonces tengo
primero de secundaria que empiezo a
revisar y vamos a suponer que yo estoy
en las primeras semanas de clases pues
estoy viendo fracciones estoy repasando
fracciones etcétera entonces yo abro mi
plataforma clase me voy a contenido sí y
voy a fracciones que es el tema o la
unidad de las primeras semanas de clases
entonces voy a decir bueno qué recursos
hay de decimales y fracciones entonces
aquí tengo videos tengo vídeos tengo
ejercicios etcétera no tengo más vídeos
más ejercicios etcétera entonces digo
cuando ok escribir decimales como
fracciones entonces aquí hay un vídeo y
quizá yo esto estoy repasando porque ya
lo vieron en sexto no entonces digo
bueno voy a ver primero de qué se trata
la vista previa para ver cómo el alumno
lo lo va a recibir esto es muy
importante para ser empáticos con estos
alumnos la vista previa como el alumno
va a percibir esto entonces esta es la
manera en que el alumno lo va a ver
puedo ver el vídeo a ver si realmente es
algo que yo quiero asignar a mí
- si es el nivel si es el tema adecuado
entre lágrimas
aquí tenemos 8 los vídeos son muy claros
como digo si ya lo han utilizado ustedes
saben que los vídeos son muy claros muy
concisos muy fáciles de entender
entonces yo me vuelvo y digo ok me gustó
este vídeo y le hago clic en este
cuadrito digo este vídeo lo quiero
asignar automáticamente se enciende el
botón de asignar y junto con este vídeo
voy a agregar voy a ver estos ejercicios
otra vez le doy en vista previa ok y me
va a decir bueno cuáles son los
ejercicios que están disponibles si para
para asignar a mis alumnos no entonces
está un poquito lento aquí en internet
vamos a ver aquí están los estudiantes
harán siete de estas 22 preguntas no
entonces en total tengo 22 preguntas de
este concepto en particular los alumnos
van a contestar solamente siete de estas
preguntas no entonces y puedo ver que
como lo va a ver el alumno es el alumno
lo recibe asignó la es el abajo tiene
dos de siete preguntas etcétera y
entonces me regreso y digo ok
dijo que entonces me gusta voy a asignar
este ejercicio sí y automáticamente aquí
me dice vas a asignar dos recursos
recuerden que para campeonato tengo que
asignar tres por semana entonces si ésta
es mi semana 1 de campeonato voy a
asignar un tercer recurso y me voy de
acá abajo y dice aquí hay otro ejercicio
desafío de reescribir decimales como
fracciones nuevamente vista previa veo
de qué se trata más o menos estas
preguntas digo que están adecuadas en lo
que vimos en clase están
de acuerdo a lo que yo estoy enseñando
entonces las voy a seleccionar y ya
tengo tres recursos para asignar y
fíjense qué sencillo es hago clic en
asignar automáticamente se me abren
estos esta ventana y me dice ok aquí es
esto es importante quieres que cada
estudiante trabaje un conjunto aleatorio
de preguntas o quieres que todos los
estudiantes trabajen el mismo conjunto
de preguntas si ustedes quieren evitar
que copien el eje se copian la tarea
entre unos y otros no que uno le
conteste la tarea al otro porque eso a
veces pasa entonces hagan esto no
entonces va a ser aleatorio que todos
reciban ejercicios diferentes o bien si
yo quiero tener algo más parejo más
uniforme puedo seleccionar que todos
reciban los mismos ejercicios me voy a
ir a la primera opción y le voy a decir
ok aquí clase y le vamos a asignar esto
y aquí le aparecen todas las clases si
yo tengo dos primeros de secundaria pues
aprovecho desde aquí
desde aquí le mando la asignó los tres
elementos a mis dos clases de primero de
secundaria oa mis tres clases de 1º y
secundaria y esto me permite ahorrar
también tiempo como docente no entonces
desde aquí asigno mis clases también
aquí puedo diferenciar por qué quizá
este repaso no lo necesiten todos
entonces yo puedo quitar aquí
seleccionar a todos y puedo seleccionar
sólo a los alumnos a quienes va dirigido
estas estas asignaturas acuérdense nada
más que para campeonato todos nuestros
alumnos deben contestarlo entonces aquí
sí es importante que seleccionar a todos
para que realmente podamos alcanzar el
100% dentro del campeonato y le ponemos
la fecha límite dentro de la semana
podemos ponerlo para fin de semana
etcétera recuerden que estos recursos
nuevamente son por semana una vez que lo
tengo puedo hasta asignar la hora si mi
clase es a las nueve digamos voy a poner
a las nueve de la mañana quiero que
hayan concluido estos ejercicios
ok y le pongo asignar y así de sencillo
es asignar tareas dentro de canacar y
como sé que el asigne correctamente si
yo me voy a mi clase que siempre va a
aparecer este menú me voy a tareas y ahí
en tareas si me aparece ya me voy a ir
aquí esto es nuevo está esta forma
digamos de ver tareas esto es totalmente
nuevo en la academy y la verdad está muy
muy padre a mí me encantó este nuevo
cambio que hicieron porque yo puedo ver
las tareas por alumno qué tareas que
alumnos me han contestado la tarea que
se ha sacado en esa tarea fíjese todas
las tareas que todas están pendientes
quién la contesto ya que se sacó puedo
desde ahí en el reporte no de ese alumno
en esta tarea en particular cuál estuvo
mal cual estuvo bien y con base a esta
información yo puedo modificar mi clase
del siguiente día yo puedo decir mañana
me voy a jalar a este alumno
y sobre esta pregunta o resolver sus
dudas no porque claramente tuvo
problemas al responder la tarea porque
están con 43 estoy yo desde aquí puedo
motivar a aquellos alumnos que
estuvieron menos del 86 no a seguir
practicando para que lleguen al 100
y jalar menos a aquellos alumnos que
están en menos de 70 para a lo mejor de
enseñarles el el concepto etcétera no
entonces esta información para nosotros
es ese en el momento mientras ellos van
contestando yo en mi casa voy recibiendo
estos reportes esta información
entonces ya no es esperar así llega la
siguiente clase a que me entreguen la
tarea a que la califique a ver quién
salió bien quien se habló
automáticamente ellos en su casa yo en
la mía puedo tener una idea muy real de
qué está pasando con mis alumnos no de
que entendieron que no entendieron y qué
modificaciones voy a hacer yo en mi
clase al siguiente día quizá estos
alumnos del 86 les voy a dar algo más no
es que sea un poco más difícil más que
requiere un poco más de esfuerzo más de
pensamiento crítico etcétera y a estos
alumnos los voy a separar del grupo y
voy a enseñarles el concepto no entonces
aquí también ya en khan academy otra
maravilla que tenemos en caracas de mí
es que ya podemos crear bueno ya tenemos
son exámenes no evaluaciones sencillas
como por concepto pero también de
evaluaciones de unidad que nos incluye
diferentes conceptos dentro de una
unidad todos los alumnos van contestando
esos exámenes y al contestar esos
exámenes ellos van ganando muchos puntos
y subiendo de nivel no entonces son
diferentes recursos nuevos que tenemos a
nuestro alcance que de verdad nos
permite como les decía diferenciar y
personalizar el aprendizaje de una
manera fácil lo que no requiere tanto
tiempo de parte nuestra
otra manera de verla es por alumno hola
hago clic por tarea y aquí en por tarea
me aparecen las tareas y aquí ya tienen
ustedes las tareas que acabamos de
nosotros de lo que acabo y ahorita de
mandar de enviar lo que viene siendo
reescribir decimales reescribir
decimales con fracciones el vídeo y
desafío de escribir decimales como
fracciones automáticamente ya me
aparecen aquí en mi lista de tareas no
tareas que están activas también yo
puedo crear tareas y guardarlas recuerda
en esa parte que si yo no estoy lista
para asignar una tarea o un examen o un
examen de unidad pero lo tengo lo veo
digo que lo voy a asignar pero hasta
dentro de dos semanas en lugar de
asignarlo lo guardo no lo guardo y ya
más adelante cuando yo esté lista para
enviar ese esa tarea la envío entonces
esa parte también es muy sencilla de
hacer y nos permite planear con la
anticipación si yo tengo tiempo hoy para
planear mis clases de la próxima semana
voy a ir seleccionando qué actividades
le voy a enviar a mis alumnos y las
guardo y llegado el momento las envío
preguntas hasta acá christina
si raúl cansino estoy de acuerdo contigo
es mucho de la nueva estructura de
tareas está mucho más visible mucho
mucho más rápida de calificar mucho más
fácil para nosotros y para porque
podemos identificar de inmediato qué
alumnos están teniendo problemas con
este concepto en particular no entonces
sí la verdad este cambio fue la verdad
un golazo por parte de khan academy me
me encantó
negociando docentes podemos entendernos
la magnitud de este cambio no y lo mucho
que nos viene a aportar como como
maestros algunas personas están pues
tiene preguntas para cómo
agregar una clase es que no entienden
dónde está
el botón
de su cuenta voy a repetir la parte de
agregar una clase cuando ustedes abren
su cuenta automáticamente al abrir su
cuenta ustedes entran a esta pestaña a
esta ventana digamos automáticamente no
ustedes no van a tener aquí nada si no
han creado nunca una clase esto está
vacío ok entonces les aparece nada más
de esta parte entonces aquí tienen sus
clases estudiantes recursos bienvenido
con su nombre y aquí en esta parte de
acá dice agregar una clase si se fijan
de la parte derecha abajo del banner que
dice campeonato empieza el 10 de
septiembre
aquí dice agregar una clase le van a
hacer clic en agregar una clase y
automáticamente se abre esta ventana
entonces desde aquí ustedes lo que van a
hacer es colocar el nombre de su clase
ok de modo vamos a poner capacitación
ok le doy siguiente
aquí voy a agregar a seleccionar qué
curso es el que este año escolar voy a
dar con esa clase entonces vamos a poner
que sea 3º de secundaria ok o que sea
algebra ahora
cuando yo estoy seleccionando mi curso
no necesariamente tengo que seleccionar
uno a mí me da la opción de seleccionar
dos o tres porque yo puedo enseñar
segundo de secundaria pero quizá empiece
con algunos conceptos de tercero
entonces esto lo puedo agregar hasta dos
o más cursos en una sola clase y además
puedo editarla más adelante si tengo que
cambiar esta información la puedo
siempre cambiar en configuración todo
vamos a poner que yo le estoy dando a
segundo de secundaria le hago clic en
siguiente y la <00:55:43.80                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                                